[Musica]
[Applauso]
ci sono paesi così piccoli che sembra
che niente possa accadere
sono i paesi dove è possibile immaginare
tutto basta ascoltare la voce profonda
che hanno che è una voce che è piena di
memorie e di passato ma che può essere
utilizzata per immaginare il futuro
io vengo da como come è una città che
vive di turismo internazionale anche è
una città che sta spesso sulle copertine
dei giornali di tutto il mondo ma è il
posto che io ho voluto rendere speciale
per me e mi piacerebbero diventasse un
po anche per voi
si chiama carato sio ed è un paesino
piccolino nella provincia di alessandria
a mezza altezza dell'appennino verso la
liguria e per me è un posto speciale
perché io li ho sentito il passato e il
futuro che si parlavano molto
chiaramente e avevano una cosa da dirsi
che per me è risultata importante
io mi sono innamorata di carta così mi
sono innamorata di cartosio quando ho
visto mario e maria teresa che sono il
primo è l'ultima di questa fila sotto ho
conosciuto mario e maria teresa che
stavano scaricando 200 sedie sotto il
sole a picco di agosto per un concerto
che si sarebbe tenuto quella sera mario
è il sindaco di cartosio maria teresa il
vice sindaco maria teresa e cardiologa e
mario vende vernici mi sono innamorata
della fatica così amorevole che stavano
mettendo nella cura di quel paese di
quelle di un impegno personale così
pieno anche di senso civico che è quello
che ha portato mario quando l'ho
conosciuto meglio raccontarmi anche lui
la fascia tricolore di sindaco se la
sente addosso sempre che è proprio per
lui molto presente e molto pesante a
volte e questa sensazione era in quel
momento tangibile come le sedie che
girano sotto il solo in quel momento era
una sensazione fortissima
mai come in quel momento
mi è stato chiaro che quello che fa
l'importanza di un comune non è il
numero degli abitanti e non è nemmeno il
bilancio che questo comune a ma il senso
del legame che c'è fra le persone
l'importanza che a quel legame viene
dato per me il senso civico è un
sentimento importante sono sicura che lo
sia anche per molti di voi anche se
magari ognuno poi lo chiama a modo suo
a me piace chiamarlo politica è una
parola un po abusata ma mi piace
chiamarlo così perché io credo che
quando noi ragioniamo dei valori che
abbiamo dei significati delle scelte che
facciamo pensando al mondo che vorremmo
pensando al futuro quello il momento in
cui noi facciamo politica quando noi
facciamo delle scelte e sulle priorità
sulle cose che ci sono che sono per noi
importanti e lo facciamo pensando a dove
vogliamo andare
quella è una dimensione politica è
quella che contiene il futuro
certo che a car tosi certe alcune volte
il futuro è stanco cartosio ha sempre
meno abitanti che invecchiano a due sole
classi in tutti e cinque gli anni delle
elementari non riescono a convincere
nessuna banca ad aprire un bancomat in
paese e la le piogge di questo inverno
che hanno lasciato isolati per alcuni
giorni alcune frazioni hanno reso
visibile questa resistenza faticosa ma
cartosio ha un respiro tutto schifo che
che mario è capace di interpretare in un
modo molto garbato e molto attento e lo
fa suonare questo respiro questa voce
fra tante difficoltà ma anche fra tante
cose belle
ad esempio le feste fruttuose che sono
delle feste molto strane e molto un mix
fra molto gusti co e un po sofisticato
perché vengono fatti insieme dalle
persone del paese e da gente che vive in
altre regioni o in altre città ma ha
scelto cartosio come posto in cui andare
a sviluppare la sua i suoi progetti
è come se chi viene da fuori riuscisse a
sentire in modo diverso il respiro di
quel paese
un mio amico mi racconta spesso che se
tu ti metti una sveglia sul naso non
riuscirai mai a leggi
le cure sono la sveglia può essere
piccolissima grandissima non riuscirai a
leggere l'ora l'unico modo per riuscire
a leggere l'ora e allontana strada gli
occhi e mettere distanze perché la
distanza che permette di capire e di
cogliere bene le cose così quel giorno
in agosto quando ero cartosio sono
andata a fare un giro per le vie del
paese e mi sono infilata in un
cortiletto che aveva in fondo un balcone
sotto c'è una piccola valle da qui
saliva in aria fresca un rumore di un
fiume questo cortile era abbastanza
sconnesso e c'era in fondo una parete
bianca tutta graffiata su cui c'era
questa lapide umberto terracini
presidente dell'assemblea costituente in
questa casa trascorse lunghi periodi dal
1946 al 1982 terracini ea cartosio era
carta uso nel 46
e a me sembrava di vederlo sul
terrazzino col vento che gli muove dei
fogli e intanto che emenda va la bozza
della costituzione che sarebbe entrati
in vigore il primo gennaio del 1948 per
alcini in quel paesino è riuscito ad
avere una forza la forza di pensare alla
costituzione che ancora oggi ha molto da
dire ha avuto una capacità di immaginare
il futuro che addensa di politica ed è
successo in un paesino piccolo così
appena ho visto questa cosa sono corsi a
damasco e sono andata a farmi raccontare
da lì in poi è stato un susseguirsi
continuo di idee di fatterelli gli
episodi di quella coabitazione e sono
tantissime ma io una cosa ve la devo
raccontare a cartosio ci sono stati dei
bambini a cui la costituzione l'ha
spiegata terracini in persona ha
chiamato dalle maestre delle elementari
in tutte un po agitate perché stavano
chiamando una personalità così
importante e lui ha fatto delle elezioni
con questi bambini e io voglio
assolutamente recuperare per trovare la
memoria
quell'incontro di quell'episodio è però
a proposito di scuola c'è c'è una
lezione che cartosio adatto a me che io
ho imparato lì che qualunque posto è
cattolico che ciascuno di noi ha una
cartosio vicina e che quello che fa la
differenza è la capacità di cercare lì
dentro i segni della memoria e farne una
voce che parla al futuro è lo sguardo
con cui noi ci prendiamo il tempo per
cogliere questa specificità e la
responsabilità del primo passo nel dire
questo
questo valore questa storia io la faccia
emergere e la condivido insieme agli
altri e questo è stato esattamente
quello che abbiamo fatto nel senso che
terracini e stato un po il sensale di
questo di questo amore fra me e la
costituzione è stata la nostra canzone e
io da agosto a cartosio ci vado da come
tutte le settimane ea furia di andarci
ho conosciuto e mario e maria teresa
sicuramente ma poi paolo ma anche tante
altre persone e mi hanno raccontato un
fatto secondo me davvero singolare di
quel territorio 30 km a nord
esattamente cioè rivalta bormida che è
il paese di neuro berto bobbio 30 km a
sud
esattamente c'è stella che il paese di
pertini
il che vuol dire che in in un raggio di
30 chilometri da un paesino di 577
abitanti che in tutto sommato non ne
fanno 5 mila nella prima metà del
novecento ci sono stati tre uomini che
hanno cambiato la storia di questo paese
che gli hanno dato un impronta che
quella che noi abbiamo ancora adesso è
un fatto è un fatto profumo particolare
e unico in qualche modo che che dice
qualcosa di quel territorio perché
pertini terracini e bobbio sono la
filosofia alla politica il diritto sono
tre osservatori i tre punti di vista tre
punti cardinali su quello che noi
abbiamo capito quel punto essere il
messaggio con la voce profonda di
cartosio e l'impegno che mi sono presa
io e che ho condiviso con mario con
maria teresa
con gli altri raccontare la voce di
cartosio e che dice costituzione e
futuro questo è il progetto che abbiamo
scelto di far rinascere a cui un amico
molto creativo ha dato un titolo che mi
piace un sacco
si chiama ricostituente la costituzione
del 2050 questo progetto è fatto di un
primo pezzo che è un festival
territoriale a cui hanno aderito tutti i
comuni tre comuni ma anche altri della
zona che animerà quel territorio
su questi temi ea noi piace pensare con
degli eventi a volte un po inusuale a
volte meno ad esempio un gioco fra
tecnologia un gioco immersivo fra
tecnologia e divertimento che farà
cercare i segni del futuro nel presente
di quei posti ma anche l'incontro con
l'autore che parla di piante come se
fossero una nazione o l'incontro quei
ragazzi che hanno inventato la
piattaforma digitale che mette in
contatto i giovani agricoltori di tutta
italia o una passeggiata nei paesi del
territorio di quella zona per cercare il
modo in cui il tempo ha cambiato il
territorio ma anche in cui lo cambierà e
quindi anche immaginando il futuro ma
questo non basta perché perché cartosio
ritrovi un ruolo rispetto al tempo della
costituzione è necessario che a tutti
questi fitti legami locali vengono
collegate delle reti più lunghe che
collegano cartosio adesso del mondo
almeno d'italia e questa è la parte più
sfidante di questo progetto
giriamo l'italia coinvolgendo i ragazzi
dai 12 ai 18 anni cioè quelli che
avranno circa 45 anni nel 2050 chiedendo
loro di scrivere la costituzione del
2050 chiedendo loro di partire dai temi
che hanno più vicini quelli che la
costituzione normalmente tratta alla
nostra attuale già tratta non so il
diritto alla famiglia lavoro i diritti
sociali oppure temi che la costituzione
solo accenna ad esempio l'ambiente o la
globalizzazione o temi che non tratta
per niente
la responsabilità dell'intelligenza
artificiale o il confine fra biologia e
tecnologia
abbiamo scelto di raccogliere da ragazzi
di tutta italia queste voci e di
portarle a cartosio per metterle a
confronto con punti di vista di
giornalisti e di esperti di tecnologie o
di filosofi ma anche con dei pensieri
meno meno ortodossi youtuber viaggiatori
fumettisti i fuochi
questo è il regalo di cartosio i giovani
e dei giovani achara tosi è uno spazio
per immaginarsi un futuro diverso un
futuro migliore questo è anche il regalo
che cartosio fatto a me e che io voglio
condividere con voi
abbiamo tutti l'opportunità di cogliere
nel posto in cui viviamo una memoria o
nel posto in cui scegliamo una memoria e
rendere questa memoria capace di
dialogare con il futuro condividendola
con gli altri perché quest'estate di
cartosio certe volte per comprendere il
presente è necessario avere la forza di
immaginare il futuro e terracini non
sapeva bene grazie
[Applauso]